the CW's arrow may have ended its eighth
season run but the legacy of Oliver
Queen will live on in the lives of the
heroes he inspired throughout the show's
timeline our deeply flawed hero strives
to become better in doing so he saves
his city and the entire multiverse
Oliver Queen is the oldest son of
billionaire developers Robert and Moira
queen always a restless bad-boy Oliver
is mostly interested in getting in
trouble with his lifelong friends Tommy
Merlyn and Laurel Lance though he
occasionally spends time with his sister
Thea he spends most of his time partying
sleeping around getting kicked out of
expensive schools and otherwise wasting
time because of boredom and apathy the
only thing he takes seriously is his
relationship with Laurel though when
they're about to move in together Oliver
panics and sleeps with laurels younger
sister Sara one fateful day Oliver takes
a voyage on a yacht with his father Sara
and a few others unbeknownst to them
Tommy's sinister father Malcolm has
sabotaged the boat when it explodes at
sea Sara is swept overboard but Robert
Oliver and an assistant survive adrift
in a life raft Robert tells Oliver the
family's wealth was built on the
suffering of others
he puts the burden of redemption on
Oliver knowing there isn't enough food
for all three of them he decides to
shoot himself and his assistant but not
before giving Oliver one final command
this begins a series of events that
reveal Oliver's tenacity and his great
fortune in the number of people who help
him Oliver makes it to the shore of an
island he later learns is called Lian Yu
which means purgatory in Chinese while
burying his father he discovers a
notebook in his pocket which he takes
with him when Oliver encounters a man
named Yahweh gulong his life changes
forever
Yao Fei turns him over to a mercenary
named Edward Fyers who is in the middle
of a complicated assassination plot
Oliver learns that fiers is holding Yao
Fei s-- daughter shado hostage and frees
her with the help of a mercenary sent to
stop fires named Slade Wilson during the
course of this adventure Oliver receives
combat training from Wilson archery
training from shado and survival
training from Yao Fei he proves to be a
quick study in each as nothing is more
motivating and acquiring a skill than
being threatened with death Oliver kills
fires and stops his plan but not before
Yahweh is killed soon a whole new
problem arises a ship called the Amazo
and a mad scientist doctor
Anthony Ivo Ivo is looking for a
strength and agility boosting serum
called mirakuru and doesn't care who he
has to kill in order to find it Oliver
winds up on a ship where he meets future
Ally and enemy Anatoly can Assaf to his
great surprise Sara Lance is on the ship
as well and is seemingly working with
Ivo however she helps Oliver and Anatoly
and joins the others on the island Ivo
gives Oliver a choice of whom he will
kill and when Oliver jumps in front of
Sara Ivo killed shado a dying Wilson is
giving the mirakuru which boosts his
powers but drives him insane in a
pitched battle on the Amazo Oliver stabs
Wilson in the eye with an arrow but Sara
is swept out to sea
Oliver wakes up to find that he's been
conscripted to work as an assassin for
the spy organization Argus his travels
take him to Hong Kong Starling city and
all the way back to Lian Yu
eventually he leaves his boss Amanda
Waller and Argus behind travelling to
Russia to make good on a promise he once
made kill a powerful Russian mobster
named Constantine Kovar Oliver nearly
winds up getting killed by the Bratva
another Russian mob trying to find Kovar
he spared by Anatoly a Bratva member
whose life Oliver saved on the Amazo
when Anatoly learns that Oliver wants to
kill kovar I'm here to kill Constantine
gore he tells him his only chance is
with the help of the Bratva that means
joining up of course membership is
rather exclusive requiring a series of
horrific pledge tasks before he's
initiated Oliver is captured and
tortured by Kovar and learns that the
Bratva cut a deal with his enemy all
seems lost until Talia al Ghul comes
along and rescues him my name is Talia
I've been looking for you Oliver learns
that the contents of the book he
retrieved from his father is a list of
every corrupt person in Starling city
and Talia convinces him that they must
die he decides it's time to go home
returning home Oliver reunites with his
mother Thea and Tommy and begins his
crusade against the corrupt businessmen
on the list
he kills some and forces others to pay
back stolen money shouting his signature
catchphrase after various attempts on
his life
Moira assigns a security guard named
John Diggle to watch over Oliver Oliver
first tries to ditch him then eventually
makes him the first member of what will
become team arrow a brilliant
information specialist named Felicity
Smoak is the next to join the team
Oliver learns that a number of prominent
businessmen including his mother and
Malcolm Merlyn are part of what they
called the undertaking they plan to set
off an explosion that will trigger an
earthquake causing destruction in the
glades a low-income section of Starling
city in a failed attempt to stop the
undertaking Oliver seemingly kills
Merlyn the ringleader of the plan but
Tommy dies as well brief stricken Oliver
returns to Lian Yu abandoning his role
as the hood Diggle and Felicity traveled
to Lian you to bring Oliver back but
this time he wants to seek justice
without killing now calling himself the
arrow he rescues his sister Thea from
hood copycats and gains a new ally Roy
Harper a new vigilante seemingly
obsessed with the Lance family also
appears to Oliver shocked it's Sara who
was not only alive but is now an ex
member of the League of Assassins Oliver
has to deal with Sebastian brother blood
who becomes mayor of Starling city under
sinister circumstances the man behind
the throne is a crazed Slade Wilson who
uses his mirakuru laced blood to develop
an army of super soldiers
Oliver is aided by his new friends Barry
Allen Cisco Ramon and Caitlin snow who
investigate brother Bloods crimes on
leave from Central City
Slade kills more of a queen and betrays
blood when he sends his army in to
destroy Starling city the future team
flash aided by the league stopped the
army with an antidote for mirakuru
Oliver tracks down Wilson who offers him
a choice of whom to save felicity or
Laurel the ever capable felicity changes
the odds when she stabs Wilson with the
cure and Oliver opts to spare Wilson's
life he's sent to a supermax prison on
Lian Yu
which Argus has been using free
turns out that it's really hard to kill
Malcolm Merlyn who draws Thea in with
the revelation that he's actually her
real father he uses a hypnotic plant to
drug Thea influencing her to kill Sara
without any memory of it Sara's death
enrages the head of the League of
Assassins Ra's al Ghul who demands
retribution
Oliver eventually engages him in a duel
and is badly beaten and left for dead he
is saved by former friends from Hong
Kong that he had once rescued Laurel
starts her training as a vigilante and
eventually joins Team arrow as the Black
Canary
Oliver reveals the truth about his own
past to Thea as well as what she did and
he trains her only nu by league custom
Oliver is forced to become the new head
of the League of Assassins seemingly
leaving his own past behind
Oliver is actually working with Merlyn
to take down the leak from the inside in
an epic battle
Oliver manages to kill Ra's al Ghul once
and for all in the aftermath
Oliver quits his role as the arrow and
runs off with Felicity to live happily
ever after happily ever after lasts
about five months before Laurel and Thea
beg Oliver and Felicity to come back and
fight damian darhk-- a sorcerer and
former assassin this time Oliver decides
on a new identity the green arrow he
vows to be a hero and symbol of hope for
the newly named Star City I am
the green arrow darks scheme involves
worldwide nuclear devastation while
saving a small number of people in an
underground arc he uses laurels father
Quinton as an informant threatening to
kill Laurel if he doesn't comply
however Oliver first has to help Barry
now known as the flash with the mystery
of Kendra Saunders and the threat of
Vandal Savage
during this team-up Oliver is distracted
because he's learned that he has a young
son named William William's mother
Samantha Clayton had been paid to keep
him hidden from Oliver Oliver decides to
run for mayor but his opponent Roubaix
Adams happens to be darks wife
dark kidnaps William and threatens to
kill him if Oliver doesn't drop out of
the mayoral race Oliver complies but he
and the team keep fighting the seemingly
invincible dark Quentin betrays dark and
as promised dark kills Laurel that
galvanizes teen arrow once and for all
as Oliver obtains light magic to
counteract dark sorcery Oliver kills
dark as the people of the city rushed to
his aid with dark finally defeated
Oliver is elected mayor in order to grow
team arrow felicity suggests a
membership drive
Renea wild dog Ramirez Evelyn Artemis
sharp Curtis mister terrific Holt and
Rory Ragman Regan joined the team later
team arrow recruits a new Black Canary
Police Officer Dinah Drake joins the
team and not a moment too soon
a new threat arrives in Oliver's life
with a personal grudge prometheus Laurel
pops up alive claiming that the legends
of tomorrow pulled her out of the
timeline to save her life this is
actually the sinister earth to Laurel
the black siren in a series of betrayals
Laurel and Evelyn are revealed to be
working with Prometheus along with Talia
al Ghul prometheus is Adrian chase
Oliver's District Attorney it turns out
chases father was one of the hoods
victim so Adrian decides to engage in an
elaborate revenge scheme destroying
Oliver's life and trying to drive him
insane eventually they are lured to Lian
Yu after William is kidnapped William's
mother is killed when chases death sets
off bombs on the island in an effort to
get to know his son better Oliver gives
up being the green arrow and entrust the
job to Diggle Oliver has a big problem
to deal with however super hacker Kaden
James and his crime empire
Oliver apparently killed James son by
accident so James seeks revenge with his
own team the black siren Anatoly who
feels betrayed by Oliver over a botched
deal and
quiet criminal named Ricardo the dragon
Diez it's revealed that Diaz is the real
brains behind James operation having
manipulated everyone else
Diaz either buys or blackmails everyone
in the city government even worse a lack
of trust splits up team arrow as Rene
Curtis and Dyna formed their own team
have you found what you're looking for
eventually black siren and Anatole
switched sides and Diaz is defeated but
escapes Oliver wakes up one morning and
finds himself living in the Flash's life
and he soon discovers that the same
thing has happened to Barry they managed
to convince everyone that they're not
crazy and seek help from Supergirl who
understands what is happening it turns
out that a cosmic being named the
monitor has given deranged psychiatrist
John degan a magical book that he uses
to change reality eventually defeating
him Oliver makes a deal with the monitor
in exchange for Barry and Cara's lives
Diaz is killed in prison but not before
he reveals his connection with a shadowy
figure named Dante the leader of a
terrorist organization called the ninth
circle another green clad Archer appears
it's amiko Adachi
another half-sister of Oliver's this
time on dad's side she initially appears
to reconcile with Oliver I need to try
and make things right but is revealed to
be the secret leader of the ninth circle
she eventually switches sides and
forgives Oliver before she's killed by
her own group the bad guys are defeated
but the now married Oliver and Felicity
go into hiding as she gives birth to
their daughter Mia Oliver and Felicity
are happy for a while with baby Mia
until the monitor comes calling Oliver
is needed to help stop the impending
crisis on Infinite Earths he teams with
Barry Cara Sara and a future version of
Mia to defend Earth 38 after suffering a
fatal wound helping to save billions of
lives
Oliver's friends use a Lazarus Pit to
resurrect him before Oliver soul is
restored to his body he decides to
accept an offer to become the new
incarnation of the spectre the cosmic
personification of justice with everyone
else in existence and I elated The
Spectre rescues his surviving friends
and they battle the anti-monitor
the cause of the crisis shouting
Oliver defeats the anti-monitor and
recreates all of existence
he also resurrects his mother Tommy and
M Eko a monument and eternal flame are
erected for Oliver by Barry in the new
headquarters of what will become the
Justice League in 2042 felicity calls
upon the monitor to reunite with Oliver
in the afterlife
and this time they really do live
happily ever after check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the DC Universe are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]